welcome to the science Asylum I Nick
lucid vivec d'Ivoire @viki d'Ivoire Viki
isn't the veca boy's name no judgment
just confused
anyway vivec asked why is there a vacuum
in space well Vicky that all depends on
what you mean by vacuum let's look it up
vacuum noun a device used for cleaning
here it is a vacuum in space I'm pretty
sure the ISS astronauts have a vacuum
dust is composed primarily of human skin
so I guess it get dirty real fast they
have an air filter they don't need a
vacuum actually they do have a vacuum
for cleaning up after themselves
sometimes I stand corrected what was
that you meant the vacuum of space the
vacuum says ok we'll try another one
vacuum verb suction from a higher
pressure to a lower pressure gases tend
to fill up all available space and get
comfortable that's usually out to the
walls of some solid container like the
ISS or as far as gravity will allow like
an atmosphere if you upset the balance
by say poking a hole in the ISS then
things get crazy the gas will expand
again to fill any lower pressure space
which in this case means outside the ISS
so yeah space has this kind of vacuum
but technically only when we're there
outer space most of the time space just
has whatever pressure it has and there's
no suction so let's try another one
vacuum noun a space devoid of matter I
mean we like to think that outer space
doesn't have any matter in it but it has
lots of matter in it it just doesn't
come in big clubs like planets or people
it's full of little itty bitty itty
bitty itty bitty particles there's solar
wind zipping out of the Sun filling the
solar system with protons and electrons
they're actually 5 to 10 protons in
every cubic meter of space in the solar
system that's 82 to 164 protons per
cubic inch or 113 to 227 million in the
space of a 10 by 10 room lots of protons
to make matters worse there's also no
clear boundary between Earth and space
we officially defined it at a hundred
kilometers but that's pretty arbitrary
the air actually fins out slowly as you
go higher and higher in fact 57.8% of
the atmosphere is under the
Mount Everest so there's not enough air
to breathe up there but I wouldn't
exactly call that outer space outer
space 99.9999 seven percent of the
atmosphere is under the 100 kilometer
line but that still leaves point zero
zero zero zero three percent in what we
officially call outer space outer space
and I mean Aurora's happen higher than
100 kilometers and that requires air
super main ultimate points there's
really no such thing as the vacuum of
space so if you could build anything in
outer space what would it be let us know
in the comments and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy